so yesterday i covered the blow up
during a senate hearing between
republican senator rand paul and dr
anthony fauci of the nih
and during that hearing dr fauci told
senator rand paul
in no uncertain terms that rand paul
doesn't know what he's talking about and
that if anyone is lying there
it's rand paul himself this apparently
has so infuriated rand paul he's on tilt
he's unhinged that rand paul now says he
is requesting a criminal referral
against dr fauci for allegedly lying to
congress
the intimidation that is being carried
out against scientists and against
medical professionals is completely
appalling
take a look at this from a recent rand
paul appearance
on fox news where he announced this
which he seems to be announcing almost
like it's some kind of badge of honor
that he's willing to take this
incredibly principled step you kicked
off
your questioning of dr fauci emphasizing
federal law
makes lying to congress a felony
punishable by up to five years in prison
is it your belief based on the evidence
senator
that he lied before congress and broke
the law
yes and i will be sending a letter to
the department of justice asking for a
criminal referral
because he has lied to congress this is
an absolutely
ghastly and dreadful direction
for the country to go in and it's a very
very dangerous one
dr peter hotes posted to his twitter
a link to an essay from 1941 by
waldemar campford called science in the
totalitarian state
and it reminds us that the targeting of
scientists and doctors has a
really ugly history in particular in the
20th century
remember that albert einstein decided to
go to the u.s at the very end of 1932
eventually came to the united states in
1933 and stayed
because of what was happening in europe
including
with reference to the world of science
and
attacks on science are simply a
totalitarian hallmark now
i'm not saying rand paul is hitler i'm
not saying rand paul is hitler
i'm not saying rand paul is hitler you
have to clarify these things
uh otherwise i will be very much
punished for the next 24 hours on
twitter
this means that when we see scientists
and doctors under attack
for doing their jobs it should really
scare us
now fortunately the current department
of justice is unlikely to actually do
anything with this request from rand
paul
under merrick garland but what would a
william barr department of justice under
donald trump have done or someone like
trump have done
in such a case it's still a stretch but
it's within the realm of
maybe they'd look at whether dr fauci
should be charged with something and
this is a
really really chilling proposition so in
terms of
the confrontation between dr fauci and
rand paul that we looked at yesterday
i'm glad that dr fauci took off the kid
gloves i'm glad dr fauci
called rand paul out fauci he almost
looked uncomfortable doing it it's not
really his thing
but how else is he supposed to deal with
the just persistent attacks on science
and scientists
attacks on his morality attacks
on his ethics and unfortunately much the
way that
trump had this longer-term effect on the
coarsening of political discourse that
went beyond
trump's presidency the legitimization
of attacks on just basic science you
know masks and vaccines
for example it i fear
and it seems pretty clear that that is
going to be seen
as a legitimate way to attack science
that the right doesn't like
for a long time this is it's very clear
that this is now a tool of the american
right-wing
and they can use it they can use as a
cudgel
science is just opinion scientists are
just politicians
you can ignore empirical statements that
come from the scientific method
just like you can ignore uh one of your
political opponents
opinion about abortion right they are
making these things equivalent it's not
as i've said before plea don't don't
hurt me i know this is
i say this often it's not about we
disagree
as to what the facts are it's they don't
understand
what are facts what types of statements
are facts and what types of statements
are opinions and
it's not new in that for example with
climate change
they've been denialist for a long time
for sure
but the mask and the vaccine stuff and
even denying the basics of how
coronavirus works for a very long time
and even
now to some degree that's more than
we can't yet say with certainty whether
we are damaging the planet long
term like i i think we are but that's a
different type of denialism
that's denialism but it's different than
the virus
is fake or masks do nothing
or the vaccine harms you or
this was created as a bio weapon in a
lab and deliberately released
the legitimization of that degree of
nonsense as being just as valid
as the science it's actually almost
postmodern in a sense
think about that because for
post-modernism has been a popular target
of the right now i've criticized
post-modernism as well but the the way
the right does it
the right comes out and says
post-modernism is the marxist enemy
uh post-modernism leads you into
um any any notion from whoever about
anything
is valuable all this different stuff
they are essentially doing a form of
that
they are saying our opinion about what
coronavirus is
should be held up as just as valid as
what doctors think
our hair brain conspiracy theories about
vaccination
should be considered just as valid and
serious as
legitimate as what medical science says
it's a form of post-modernism and
post-structuralism in which they are
engaged
it's a total hypocrisy that shouldn't
surprise us but it's also
very very dangerous and uh you we should
be glad
that the merit garland department of
justice i can't imagine
is going to take even remotely seriously
rand paul's request
for a criminal referral against dr
anthony fauci
one of our sponsors today is helix sleep
and it's a sponsor
i'm thrilled about because i sleep on a
helix mattress
at home and it's just the perfect
mattress one of the best things about
helix is
you don't have to guess which mattress
do i need which one will be good for me
you take their famous sleep quiz on
their website you tell them your body
type
your sleeping position your back pain
issues you might have
and they will pair you with a mattress
that will be perfect for you
i took the sleep quiz the mattress they
suggested was exactly what
i needed i often get too hot at night
the mattress keeps me cool
it's not too soft it's not too firm the
texture is right
and i've just been getting way better
sleep you only buy a mattress
every decade or so don't get stuck with
something that's not perfect for you and
all helix mattresses come with a 10-year
warranty
and they'll even come to your house and
pick it up within 100 days
if you don't love it but i think you
will all of my viewers will get up to
200
off your order and you'll get two super
premium pillows
for free when you go to the link right
underneath this video